all my condos sold all my stuff packed
my car and i drove straight to
california from baltimore it's like okay
i don't know anything about the gym
business so i'll just email a bunch of
gym owners and see if they'll just like
let me work for free i emailed like 40
gems one guy got back to me and he was
like yeah come on out you can work for
free yes i was like all right awesome
showed up at this guy's doorstep and he
was like this is really creepy i was not
really actually expecting you to do this
i was like what do you want me to do and
he's like i don't know like i have stuff
to do you can hang out here for a little
bit he's like where are you staying and
i was like i don't know i just got here
i just drove to your gym from my house
in baltimore you have nowhere to stay i
was like no i figured i figured out
where was this located in california so
you drove from baltimore to california
and he was he was surprised you even did
it yeah you didn't call him while you
were driving like on the way like hey
man just let you know i'm like i'm on
the way i mean we talked once and i was
like all right i'll be there i didn't
even have his phone number
you just showed up at his house i showed
a business gym